what does the world Between Worlds mean
for the second half of Ahsoka well for
one thing it presents an opportunity for
Ahsoka and Anakin to reconcile it's
possible that Anakin has some deeper
knowledge of what's going on in the
cosmos that could help Ahsoka stop
thrawn more likely though he'll help her
navigate some of her personal baggage to
reconnect with herself and the force
since Rosario Dawson started playing the
character in The Mandalorian season 2
Ahsoka has felt much more closed off and
stoic but it's possible that Anakin can
help her find her balance once more if
Ahsoka is in the world Between Worlds
she might also be able to hop on a
shortcut to wear Sabine and the others
are all going there's no reason to think
the force realm couldn't stretch across
multiple galaxies and since it allows us
residents to travel through time she
could even get there before Morgan's
hyperspace ring the truth is very little
has ever been revealed about the world
Between Worlds that means that Dave
filoni and the creative team of Ahsoka
could use it for any number of reasons
it also makes the next four episodes
kinda difficult to predict